well good afternoon everyone
um we just had a
lunch meeting
conference call this time
aware growing concern about
the rise of coronavirus and
we adjusted our meeting
to to uh reflect our concern about being
extra safe
and conducting what we believe is
essential work
uh for the american people
the subject of additional coronavirus
relief is on the minds of
lots of our members you've already
spoken to
probably senator collins senator romney
and others who've been meeting with
democrats
about a possible way forward
we received a proposal through a letter
from speaker pelosi and senator schumer
last
night let me tell you where i think we
are
leader mccarthy and i've been in
discussions with the secretary of the
treasury
and the president's chief of staff to
try to ascertain
what the president would actually sign
into law
and i think we have a sense of what that
is i laid that out in the call that we
had
uh just a little while ago
we're going to send that out to all the
officers and get some feedback
to see how our members react
to a proposal that we can say for sure
would be signed into law i think the one
thing we all agree on
is that we don't have time for messaging
games
uh we don't have time for lengthy
negotiations
the issue is do we want to get a result
and i like to remind everybody that the
way you get a result
you have to have a presidential
signature so i felt the first thing we
needed to do is to find out what
the president would in fact sign we
believe we've got the answer to that
we're vetting that on our side and then
we'll
let you know later whether we think uh
there's any
uh way forward but certainly we know we
can
say i hope that this is something
that would be signed into law by the
president
be done quickly deal with the things
that we can agree on
now and i think we all know that after
the first of the year there's likely to
be a discussion
about additional some additional package
of some size
next year depending upon what the new
administration
wants to pursue
between now and the end of the year we
have to um wrap up a lot of the
unfinished business of this congress and
so we've got a number of
nominees to important agencies uh
and uh judgeships that we will need to
be acting on and filling
we've got to fund the government
obviously and of course we have to pass
a defense authorization bill
as well all of which we will have to try
and get done
hopefully the next week or two depending
on how much cooperation we have
as the leader pointed out the issue of
chronovirus relief
is also a subject of discussion and
i think in terms of the um any of these
year-end
negotiations could be if there's an
agreement
wrapped up and considered as part of a
spending bill or perhaps separately but
in any case
uh it would have to get a presidential
signature have to get 60 votes in the
senate
and obviously a majority in the house of
representatives and so the question is
what does that look like and will there
be enough movement among democrats
to enable us to get a an agreement and i
think what we've seen
of course so far we we have now not once
but twice
passed or i shouldn't say past but
gotten 52 republican votes
in the senate a majority if you could
pass it at a majority
in the senate um four billion fights for
vaccines
funding schools uh provides additional
assistance for
unemployment insurance and and also
replenishes the ppp program which helps
a lot of our small businesses who are
struggling
and workers who work there those are all
things that the democrats say that they
agree upon
but they have insisted at least up until
now on a bloated
messaging bill uh in the or on the order
of a couple uh
two and a half trillion dollars or
thereabouts which is something that
obviously would not pass in the senate
get signed the law by the president so
the question is what can we get through
the house 60 votes in the senate
and a presidential signature on and i
would hope that
in the course of the next couple of
weeks as we are debating the year-end
issues that we can get some agreement on
something that
fits those basic parameters like i said
we had all but one republican
who have now voted now once but twice
for a bill that addresses those critical
needs and things that i think both sides
agree need to be addressed
but it will require a level of
cooperation compromise from the
democrats that we have not
seen or witnessed yet in order to get
that done
but i'm hopeful i think the american
people need help they need relief our
small businesses need help
our frontline workers need help our
schools need help
and obviously we want to make sure that
we're investing everything we can in
the vaccines and the therapies that will
help us defeat this
virus so those are areas of agreement a
bipartisan agreement the question now is
whether or not democrats are going to
come to the table
in a meaningful way and help us get
something across the finish line
um nancy pelosi has been stubbornly dug
in
uh since uh she passed her bloated
messaging bill about six and a half
months ago stubbornly vote uh dug in
against
doing a coronavirus relief bill
in a cooperative way as a matter of fact
right before the elections
she said that she would not budge
she's been dead set for using the
pandemic
as a way to push a far left agenda
because she was going to use this and
pick up 15
to 20 seats for democrats in the house
well what happened
as a result of her actions republicans
picked up
over 10 republican seats in the house of
representatives
why because the democrats refused to
deal and address the number one issue
which is on the minds of the american
voters
which was relief for coronavirus and
dealing with the disease
so now here we are at a point where we
have an increased number of cases around
the country
and around the world you say so what is
the house of representatives doing
this week so i looked into it well they
have a bill that is going to be taken up
in the rules committee tomorrow
it's called the moore act i didn't
didn't know what exactly that stood for
so i looked into it researched it
this is pelosi's priority
marijuana opportunity reinvestment act
now i don't know exactly what's in that
bill but that is the priority of the
house
right now i don't know if it has to do
with decriminalization
legalization of marijuana making it
easier for
our kids to get marijuana in our
neighborhoods whatever it is
that is today's priority of the
incredibly
shrinking nancy pelosi run house of
representatives
that's not what the american people are
talking about that's not what i heard
about in wyoming this weekend
what i heard about is all the good news
about the vaccine
people looking forward to having that
available to them
well the republican relief bill has
money for distribution of the vaccine
the pelosi schumer approach well they
really do shortcut the vaccine
the republican bill has money for
paycheck protection the senate bill that
we're working on
that's what small businesses are asking
for and the workers are asking for it
has money for
to help kids get back to school safely
so they don't fall further behind
this is the path forward for our country
the republican bill is sizable it is
significant
and it is the path that the american
people want to follow
i think also safe to say that today
senator shelby said we were making real
progress
on the omnibus spending bill i know
on the part of the labor age education
bill i think we're down to only
discussing
report language with the full committee
help we're going to
close that out the four members house
and senate
have worked through that bill over the
last couple of weeks now and i think
we're getting to a good place there i
hope we are
with the rest of the bill the other
topic i wanted to talk about today was
the
arms sale the uh f-35 sale to the uae
it appears sometime this month there'll
be a congressional vote
on that issue my personal view is it
would be a big mistake
not to move forward with that arms sale
the
israel is supportive i think it may be
the only thing
that netanyahu and gad said agreed on
since they formed their coalition
government
that this sale should go forward they
say that understanding that there would
be a qualitative difference
between the uae f-35 and the israel f-35
and then another difference
between what we have but for 20 years
now three different administrations
uh we've increased it we have
increasingly worked closely with the uae
on defense
issues on the ground together in the air
together
in at least six different extended
deployments
the uaa has been there clearly the
abraham accords
what's happened with bahrain following
and i think others to follow that
will be impacted by whether we continue
to have the kind of cooperation on
defense
issues that we've had with the uae again
for three different administrations
that will come up uh it will not
successfully be stopped by the congress
i don't believe but it's a debate that
we ought to be thinking about
i certainly think we should continue
with that arms sale
first i want to welcome back my senior
senator chuck grassley to the united
states senate
and our work schedule whether chuck is
working from his iowa farm whether he's
working from his office
here in the united states senate or
whether he's teleworking
because of the virus chuck grassley
works
he is always working many of you have
probably heard the chuck norris
jokes out there you know the the dark is
afraid of chuck norris
well we have our own chuck grassley
jokes too and right now the covid
is afraid of chuck grassley so we are
just very thankful
to have him back and in good health and
continually working
for iowans he is just such a tremendous
asset to our great state of iowa
and we wish him continued health uh as
we are approaching the
end of our congressional session we do
have a number of things that need to be
done and i just want to address
two of those that some of my colleagues
have already mentioned
one is making sure that we have a
coronavirus bill
that is done just earlier today our
governor of the great state of iowa kim
reynolds
did state that congress needs to come
together and get a bill done
we have people across the state of iowa
and across this nation
that are hurting we want to keep a
strong economy we want to keep our
citizens
safe and healthy and then finally we do
have the national defense
authorization act that is hanging in the
balance
we need to work together to ensure that
we get this completed
we have done this for many decades now
in a bipartisan
fashion we need to do it again it
includes a lot of provisions that are
very good for our service men and women
things as simple as body armor for
females
in a body armor that conforms to the the
size and shape of a female
so simple well that's included in this
national defense
authorization act so it is vitally
important that we are putting our
service members their
their safety first and getting that over
the finish line
so i'm just encouraging our democrats
come back to the table let's work
through these issues
let's get the ndaa done and let's get
this coronavirus built on
thank you
well i welcome everyone back i hope you
had a blessed thanksgiving
it's of course december 1st and uh we
still don't have a coronavirus relief
package
that has been passed signed into law by
the president
and is providing relief to the american
people look for
people are hurting um they're beyond
frustrated with this whole exercise
republicans have put forward a package
that as the leader has emphasized
can actually be signed into law one that
provides assistance to schools and
students one that provides assistance to
our hard-hit small businesses uh one
that provides additional resources for
testing so
uh why don't we go ahead and pass what
we can all agree upon
what we know can be signed into law and
then we can
debate and negotiate and give further
consideration to
additional measures as it relates to
small businesses i'll tell you who's
your small businesses have been
absolutely hammered as have so many
others
around the country a recent nfib survey
indicated that nationally 75 of their
members
would either consider or would go ahead
and apply for
a second round of ppp assistance the
sort of assistance
that is included in the senate package
so whether it's
ppp assistance or
inclusion of the restart act the
legislation
bicameral bipartisan that i put together
uh with senator bennett of colorado uh
it now has incidentally 58 co-sponsors
with the addition of senator perdue of
georgia
here in the u.s senate uh 180 in the
house of representatives again
bipartisan uh so um i'm going to
continue to push
on on this small business front and on
the other fronts i mentioned
provide the much needed relief to the
american people
unfortunately it seems the house is
focused on other priorities we just
heard that
they're focused on on something
pertaining to marijuana
and uh giving more consideration to
marijuana policy
before years end that can be debated
uh but the far left needs to sort of
cool their jets right now
as we deal with the serious business and
the plaintiff
uh requests of of our constituents
around the country
you alluded to the bipartisan framework
that came out today
have you had a chance to look at that
and since you're talking about the
importance of the president signing
something
the house would have to pass something
too so why wouldn't a bipartisan
proposal that could potentially also
pass in that body be a better way to go
yeah we just don't have time to waste
time
we have a couple of weeks left here
obviously it does require bipartisan
support to get out of the congress but
it requires a presidential signature
and this government is in place for sure
for the next
and i think the place to start is are we
actually
making a law or are we just making
a point and i think the way you make a
law for sure
is you know you've got a presidential
signature so
we'll see how it goes forward i think
the one thing we all agree on as i said
waiting till next year is not an answer
we need a
targeted relief bill including things
that we can
agree on
[Music]
house majority leader has said that
house democrats are likely to bring you
back new march next year
two years and republican colleagues say
that with five and likely being
controlled administration
republicans should consider bringing
back their marks here in the senate
do you have an opinion about that
victory
house majority of your state lawyer says
house democrats are bringing back
your marks next year yeah i haven't
given any real thought to that i
i did hear that that horrier said that
that's a decision obviously the
majorities decided to make over there
and it'll be interesting to see how the
republicans in the house respond to
relief it does it need to ride on the
government funding bill
what should we expect kind of on a
horizon when it needs to come out when
it needs to come to fruition
well first we're working really hard to
finish up the omnibus bill as
senator pointed out obviously given the
challenges of moving
things across the senate floor speedily
that would be a vehicle to add on
whatever coronavirus relief bill
we know will get a presidential
signature and
obviously as was discussed earlier
you'll have to have democratic votes to
get through the house
but i think it will all likely come in
one
in one package
over the years about the electoral
process integrity
in the election why have you not spoken
out and why have you been quiet i mean
the president's
claims of the election has been rigged
and it's been stolen from them
as i've said repeatedly we have this
government for the next three weeks for
sure
and what i'm focusing on is trying to
accomplish as much as we can
during this three-week period which
requires dealing with the government
that we have
right now the future will take care of
itself as i've said repeatedly we're
going to go through these processes
the electoral college is going to meet
december the 14th
there'll be an inauguration january 20th
you keep saying that the president you
want to you want a bill that would pass
that would have the president's
signature but he's been far away from
senate republicans he's been
willing to go as high as 1.8 trillion
are you coming up on your number and is
there anything from
the compromise package that you saw
today which included the state and local
labor well what i'm doing
maybe i wasn't very clear about what i'm
doing is talking to secretary mnuchin
has been deputized by the president
to indicate what he's willing to sign
and
leader mccarthy and i went over with
meadows and minutian this morning
for sure what we know will get a
presidential signature
that's where we began the discussion at
lunch today
i'm sending that proposal to all offices
that's probably been done by now
we're going to get feedback about how
our members
feel about it and then to determine the
way forward
[Music]
well as you may recall i made them
change my vote and made a motion to
reconsider
so we can reconsider it in the future
thanks a lot everybody